a distinguished career at the University
of Pittsburgh is still drafted behind
five other quarterbacks despite those
long odds he played well enough to hurt
a statue outside the Dolphin Stadium
which is actually only slightly less
mobile than he was as a quarterback
[Music]
after a decade of playing in the NFL
Marino burst onto the national scene in
the 1995 film Ace Ventura pet detective
also appeared in the Hootie & the
Blowfish video I only want to be with
you I did I never made Darius Rucker cry
please welcome
[Music]
[Applause]
that was I enjoyed that okay yes that's
cool I was worried about the statue line
not well there isn't it's true
what was your 40-yard dash out of
college or say four eight okay like that
I mean I wasn't yeah so it's reasonable
yeah reasonable
yeah nice are getting the operations
Annette what's up what were you at the
end of your career sixth flat you look
good
you like yeah how do you do it where you
look better every year
it's Nutrisystem you know joining us on
behalf of Nutrisystem well thank you Dan
we'll get to that later that coming out
of here you know when I we were thinking
about mention who Tina Blowfish they're
going back on tour
I don't yeah yeah yeah I met them 24
years ago so they're celebrating their
25th year how many concerts do you think
you've gone to with Hootie the Blowfish
at least 25 Abbi yeah okay so Darius
Rucker grew up a Dolphins fan because he
did and then when you find out he names
his daughter after you yeah it's right
it's cool yeah he's a fan so called her
name is Danny yeah so when does he call
you and say I'm gonna name my daughter
he didn't he didn't call me okay but
then you find out found out later so
that's yes yeah he said he was actually
now do you know this story about he was
thinking about you when he's been
cheated before yes that's funny yeah
yeah so during the process he thought
about you it's amazing he knew exactly
[Laughter]
have you ever signed an autograph and
it's become a 10-2 with with fans you
know I think that's happened before I
don't think they told me they were gonna
do it but I've yes I know and someone's
arm before and then your jerseys retired
by the Miami Heat
is that right no no they they use 13 but
they just put me up like a community oh
okay
okay Pat Riley did it but you were
baseball Michael Jordan's doing is in
the stadium - oh it is yeah so you were
a - sports star growing up baseball
drafted by the Royals sure
so could you look at what Kyler Murray
is doing and like what if you had to do
it again we know you got a Hall of Fame
career but how much did you love
baseball
did you love baseball more in football
um when I was younger yeah sure but it's
time went on I think I felt like I would
be a better football player and I think
I made the right decision
ya know I mean yeah but at the same time
it's different circumstance cuz this
kids in college you already won the
Heisman you know I was coming out of
high school so there was a bigger gap
there you know and like Elway was he was
already playing at Stanford he's playing
yeah it was a little different
circumstance and and I was also
wondering about today's rules with
quarterbacks that you know we keep
waiting for Tom Brady to retire and my
whole point is why would you retire if
you're the rules benefit you they're
hard to get to you everything it feels
like is less than two seconds of getting
the ball and you probably in it out
anyway yeah so you had the quickest
release of anybody pride in the history
of the game I mean you could just stand
back there and and play so why would
Brady we retire I I would tell him not
to retire I mean if he's playing at a
high level you know once your problem is
once you're done you're done yeah no
there's no like coming back though so I
think he can play for a few more years
he's playing at a high level what do you
see when - what do you see 42 right 41
41 yeah couldn't get him older any could
he play 45 but maybe I mean but what was
your alarm like at 45 not your mobility
your knees but you see my arm was still
pretty good yeah my legs is really what
I mean I could still I'm not today I
could still throw halfway decent how far
could you throw it now yeah no you can
do it farther than now okay 70
okay I don't know I don't know that's a
big jump from 40 to 70 how far could you
throw it when you could really throw be
around 70 yards okay cuz Elway had a
great arm yes he did Randall Cunningham
had a greater mm-hmm now they said that
he could probably throw it 80 yards
Randall I saw Randall throat maybe
further than that at those quarterback
challenges we had yeah he threw like 84
yards and mahomes looks like he could
bring kin sing it to ya
what do you see when you see Mahone I
see a young kid that can control it from
any angle you know his army yeah yeah
and it's not is he's little unorthodox
in his style because it's not like you
know turn and throw make sure your
shoulders but he gets it done and his
arm you know can make any throw really
that he needs to make but can you teach
he mentioned something about playing
baseball and playing shortstop and you
throwing it from side or me throw it
over to top or making a turn in a double
play I think that probably some of that
sent his passing game but you were a
pitcher weren't you pitch played
shortstop drafted to be a third baseman
but but did help did pitching help you
deliver a football or did football help
you deliver a baseball I never really
thought about that question I think it's
uh are there similar principles no no
it's uh baseball you're throwing a curve
yeah some of it but you're still
planting on that left foot yeah yeah
it's bought it's your it's your
technique and all it's this the same but
as far as throwing a football you gotta
turn you turn your hand that way no you
do yeah that's how it spirals I well I
played freshman football so I have an
idea like we so we have some was it
flagged
no no it's tackle okay we were three and
six I couldn't pass it
no we but I yeah we have something
coming I mean we both play quarterback I
mean you can tell by looking at this
yeah I mean I look like look like you
could have played yeah yeah we're a
Freshman team yeah
all right when I started but no I was
wondering about that when when you when
you're looking at form and you try to
create like everything that's right it's
similar but whose form if you said
you're building the ideal quarterback oh
and give me arm so probably nowadays
it's probably Aaron Rodgers okay you
know cuz his ability to throw the ball
he can throw from different angles get
like the kid mahomes can do it okay
so mobility ability arm strength
accuracy also Aaron Rodgers is the
perfect quarterback as far as his
ability to play the game and you know as
far as throwing I'll know if he's
perfect no one's perfect but yeah he
could he could bring it when you're the
other quarterback in the Super Bowl as
Jared Goff is mm-hmm how does he use
that to his advantage where we're
focusing on Brady we're focusing on
Belichick and then here's Jerry was not
as much attention but if there is
attention it's the Super Bowl no matter
what but maybe there's not as much
attention because Tom is getting so much
because he's been here every year for
the last 20 years you know he's there
there every year so maybe that'll help
from you know his standpoint maybe so
it's not too big for him but just take
advantage of he's got an opportunity
great opportunity do you remember what
that pregame speech or that locker room
was when you went out for your Super
Bowl you know coach Schuler's pregame
lockers speeches weren't I mean it was
more just about getting doing your job
you know what you got to do we didn't
play music and a lot you know now they
play a lot of music there was no music
everybody was kind of concentrating on
what they got to do but it's hard to
remote spin a while
so I don't remember the pregame speech
but when you go out there I I remember
you know a troy aikman talked about like
you went out and like you almost want to
throw up like it's so big and you've
waited for this moment all you want to
do is have somebody hit you you just
want the game to start game start yeah I
mean from what I remember I was young I
still may be the youngest one ever
played a quarterback I don't know what
were you 24 53 23 yeah but uh but I
remember like it felt like I was
supposed to be there you know like it
was well the season you had yeah right
like we were supposed to be there I felt
pretty comfortable
that's probably why we lost yeah so but
Roy's right I sent is when you know you
get the feel of the game gets going it's
really you know it's a football game and
you talked about this before that you
think you're going to get back and
there'd be no reason for you not to
think you're gonna get back very true
and and you know so the further you get
away from it then you're more like God
is that the only time I'm gonna get to a
Super Bowl so yeah later in my career I
started to think that way yeah I mean
that might be the only time and that's
why you know you continue to play and
you do everything you can to put
yourself in that position but I
definitely would I I was 23 I thought
for sure I'd be back a few times how
many how many touch don't you think you
could throw in today's game yeah you
know let's say you're 23 years of age 60
do you really ask me this question last
year yeah and I want to know if it's the
same age that's 62 no because every time
I want I don't have to prove it so it's
good yeah I watched today's quarterbacks
and I can't help but think how far head
you were of every one of these guys so
what we yes we were doing things that
you know and you were throwing deep
balls to it wasn't there was no bubble
bubble screens we didn't have that you
know we were going down the field yeah
that's the one thing why they get more
yardage now because it's the rpoS you
know that run past options and you
wouldn't have the run part of the run it
was part of our offense yeah we would do
that but we didn't I mean that wasn't
back then you're throwing a ball down
the field you know yeah I mean now it's
just like dump dump dump done in a
little jet sweep that they throw it at
the pass
Tom Brady has rushed for a thousand
yards in his career okay I'm saying that
sounds pretty impressive I mean it's not
necessarily that count all the kneel
down well he kneels forward I don't
think yeah every time I think it's a
yard they take a yard no he talked to
the official when he got to a thousand
he said I'm gonna I'm gonna kneel
forward don't count that as me kneeling
back well that shouldn't be legal you
know me you're G Rushmore yes you
yeah 87 Paulie 87 on the note but once
again I ran for more yards than that
because every time we want a game you
take the kneel down at the end the
victory snap you know what I'm saying
that's goes against you well you didn't
win a thousand games therefore you lot
of thousand yard lot I know you're part
of Miami Super Bowl committee yes yes we
already got the Super Bowl so I know but
we're yes we're getting it but so for
neck next year we're yeah yeah so part
of the committee and uh and just we're
excited about having in Miami
can we stay at your house no alright cuz
I could just bring it could I buy it I
think but it's the 11th time 11th time
it's gonna be in Miami so that's pretty
cool you're also a part of Nutrisystem
every year at Super Bowl you come in you
talk about how great it's been for you
would you like to give this audience
opportunity and understand exactly thing
is that new persistent for men monday is
the biggest diet a decision for men of
the year because the one-two playoffs
and Dorner Super Bowl no one's gonna
want to start a diet so Monday is that
day to make a decision to go on a diet
and I've been this spent 13 years I've
been working with them so it's been a
good relations and also I heard I don't
know if this is true but the average
football fan gains ten pounds during the
season is that I said about right yes
yes but you don't I don't know how about
you look at me you look great thank you
yeah it's nice appreciate that
Nutrisystem dot-com to get started today
and you can look like that now their
results may vary but you may end up
looking like Dan Marino outstanding yeah
you may look like him during the
commercial break McLovin has his wide
receiver gloves on okay and what what
did you want to say Marino I don't know
when he say you could throw it 40 yards
I don't know if I even need gloves with
Dan
well last year you yeah no I and I yes I
was wearing gloves that were old like
from the 90s these new gloves yeah it is
that's performance enhancing those
gloves are performance enhancing right
all right kids gloves if you're watching
on audience channel 239 Direct TV or the
NBC Sports Network you can see Dan try
to ruin McClellan's life coming up
it's Nutrisystem dot-com for everything
you need one in four football fans claim
to gain an average of 10 pounds during
the football season start your diet on
super Monday after Super Bowl Sunday
perfect thank you Dan for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]